wie bitte da wurde einfach mal so ein
neues teilchen entdeckt eigentlich waren
die fachleute auf der suche nach etwas
ganz anderem doch dann stellten sie ein
bislang unbekanntes objekt auf es
handelt sich um ein quasi teilchen
konkret also um einen bindungs zustand
aus zwei löchern zwei elektronen und
licht und dieses exotische speed on
erlaubt uns super spannende einblicke in
die wechselwirkung von materie und licht
und das ist enorm wichtig für zahlreiche
technische anwendung klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt es spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts los geht's willkommen bei
modellversuchen taucht dieses mysteriöse
teilchen immer wieder auf und das zum
erstaunen der fachleute denn das
forschungsteam aus wien hatte bei seinen
analysen eigentlich ganz andere dinge im
visier
doch die entdeckung des exotischen
pythons in einem kristall kamen
dazwischen es ist also ein echter
zufallsfund genau genommen handelt es
sich um ein sogenanntes quasi teilchen
in der fachsprache ist dass der begriff
für sehr exotische und oft kurzlebige
zustände bei denen mehrere teilchen oder
lehrstellen miteinander in einem
kristallgitter verkoppelt sind sie
stehen chemisch gesehen quasi neben der
familie der elementarteilchen die man
ebenso kennt wie neutronen elektronen
oder protonen die quasi teilchen dagegen
können nicht isoliert existieren dazu
sagt der physiker carsten held der an
der neuen studie beteiligt war das
einfachste quasi teilchen ist ein loch
stellen wir uns etwa vor dass in einem
kristall viele atome regelmäßig
angeordnet sind und an jedem atom ein
bewegliches elektronen sitzt nur an
einem bestimmten atom fehlt das elektron
man spricht von einem loch oder anders
formuliert wenn in einem kristallgitter
ein elektron an einem atom fehlt
entsteht eine lücke und diese ist
positiv geladen und genau diese ladung
kann sich durch das gitter bewegen also
wie ein herkömmliches teilchen
physikalisch gesehen verhält sich diese
lücke geben ähnlich wie ein normales
teilchen eben allerdings mit der
ausnahme dass solch ein quasi teilchen
eben nicht isoliert existieren kann
sondern nur im zusammenhang
mit einem anderen teilchen die fachleute
kennen schon seit längerer zeit ein
komplexes quasi teilchen namen sexy ton
das vor allem in der halbleiterphysik
enorm wichtig ist es handelt sich um
einen bindungs zustand der aus einem
loch und einem elektron besteht das
elektron ist negativ geladen und das
loch entspricht der abwesenheit einer
negativen ladung somit ist es positiv
geladen und beide ziehen sich
gegeneinander an dieser bindung zustand
kann durch licht angeregt werden und
genau solche aktionen hatte das wiener
forschungsteam bei seiner analyse
eigentlich im visier dazu schreibt das
forschungsteam wir entwickelten computer
simulationen mit denen man effekte in
festkörpern quantenphysikalische genau
berechnen kann doch immer und immer
wieder spürten sie etwas ganz anderes
auf ein äußerst mysteriöse objekt und
zwar das neuartige und sehr exotische
quasi teilchen das aus zwei elektronen
und zwei löchern besteht die durch
photonen an die außenwelt gekoppelt sind
die beiden elektronen und zwei löcher
können durch zwei faktoren zusammen
gehalten werden und genau dadurch kommt
das neue quasi teilchen auch zusammen
nahmen dazu die wissenschaftlerin anna
kauf der name python kommt daher dass
sie zwei elektronen und zwei löcher
durch ladungs dichte fluktuation oder
spin fluktuationen zusammengehalten
werden die von einem gitter punkt des
kristalls zum nächsten ihren charakter
immer um 180 grad um kehren also um
einen winkel von pye gemessen in radiant
diesen ständigen wechsel von plus nach -
kann man sich vielleicht wie einen
wechsel von schwarz nachweis auf einem
schachbrett vorstellen dass quasi
teilchen entsteht spontan und zwar dann
wenn ein foto als ein lichtteilchen
absorbiert wird das python verschwindet
dagegen wenn wieder ein photon emittiert
also abgegeben wird und auch wenn die
fachleute das quasi teilchen bislang nur
im computer aufspüren können
sind sie sich ihrer entdeckung ganz
sicher denn es taucht immer wieder auf
und das in unterschiedlichen modellen
und in unterschiedlichen materialien
nun stehen weitere experimente und
analysen an um endgültig klarheit zu
bekommen
doch schon jetzt steht fest dass diese
entdeckung eine ganz besondere ist denn
das python
zu weiteren wichtigen erkenntnissen
führen zum beispiel zu der kopplung von
licht und festkörpern und das ist ein
thema das in vielen technischen
anwendungen entscheidend ist sei es in
der photovoltaik oder in der
halbleitertechnologie das größte
sonnenkraftwerk der erde ein spannendes
beispiel der photovoltaik von hyperraum
tv anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
haben wir kanal bis dann bleibt dran